welcome to another episode of not too
deep the award-winning a podcast I'm
your host grace and helping the first
this is a very exciting episode we have
Marybeth not to be confused with
Meredith Monroe if you don't know her
she's an amazing comedian actress writer
and new mom you've seen her on
workaholics she's on the good place and
she's just genuinely the kindest
sweetest woman that plays basically a
straight-up [ __ ] constantly on
television and so enjoy this wonderful
conversation with Meredith Monroe are
you craving flavor and refreshment this
summer pick up one of the three flavors
of Bud Light shilada original extra lime
and the newest member of the family
mango but like shilada is perfect for
drinking at brunch on the beach or just
hanging out with friends in the Sun pick
up a bubbly chill out of today and learn
more at Bud Light calm
Bud Light gelada flavor that refreshes
[Music]
Mary Beth thank you for being here oh my
gosh this is so fun thank you having me
well tell me okay
I really want to know this story already
that you were turning your phone off and
said that you've had a problem before
because it went off in a testing yes
which people that don't know what
testing basically means you've made it
to the final countdown of getting onto a
TV show and you are testing in front of
directors writers producers like the the
main people you want it to be your most
professional where they're like oh she's
not only amazing - yeah I know phone
ringing your phone going off kind of
shatters all that but they were very
cool and I knew it was it was a very
casual testing day it was before the
network like before I actually went in
front of network so it was just the
creator of the show the executive
producer and the casting person it was
fine it was still just really
embarrassing very easily fixable it's
just the easiest thing you can do yeah
you hate to be that personally um okay I
have a bone to pick with you a little
bit oh well they've got it's gonna get
spicy so soon yeah
been trying to do my research on you but
it's really hard because there's nothing
out there on me well that's sort of
because you have not posted on Instagram
since 2015 and as someone that lives and
thrives on the internet this is
problematic to me it was anticipating
this was going to be a subject of
conversation I want to start off with
why okay so it's a lot about laziness
with me yeah really um you know and I'm
so old school like I still kind of keep
up Facebook yeah just so embarrassing to
say no that's good that's a that's a
thriving community I don't keep up with
Facebook so that's me being lazy but
also it's really helping you out to
those social media that you do do and
and I kind of feel like i weirdly missed
the boat I think generationally I know
that sounds so strange but I'm in that
weird middle generation where we didn't
have cell phones for a time and then got
cell phones right we were like
technology was like thrown at us yeah it
wasn't something that I kind of came up
with and I feel like even that five six
years difference it would have probably
helped me social media wise laughs yeah
um but I don't have any hang-ups about
it I think it's great I think it shy
hello you're at it no I think it's
healthy I think the way you are living
your life I almost got jealous and I was
like wow doesn't post it in four years
really especially kind of ambitious and
aspiring we're gonna see how it plays
out I think I think my career might be
helped greatly if it was more out there
so we do Twitter I see you on Twitter
doing stuff I'm more on Twitter and I'll
like be like I got a show LA yeah I'm
really I'm just really bad about it and
I do think I went down a road in the
initial phases of Twitter where I didn't
like how much pressure I put on myself
initially yeah and when I feel like
anxiety lore something about something I
am kind of like bye yeah done because I
don't want any added anxiety that I
already don't experience from career or
for sure name it you know relationships
whatever foundation so I feel like I
looked at it as like there's this
thing that I'm voluntarily doing yes and
then I also do have some friends where
I'm like you need to not have
instagramming perspectives yet like oh
no now this is affecting your family
yeah like this is really bad so I do
have feelings when it becomes an issue
yeah I feel like you have a healthy
relationship I like it what you don't
know is also the I completely relate to
the anxiety that comes with the pressure
of having to like you know forward your
career by maintaining like a social
media presence yeah some way shape or
form and also getting like just bogged
down by how like gross it can be and hey
yeah just like mean it can be very mean
I wanna say I just had a child like
three months ago or so which we can talk
about later yes but I do I have I I felt
like I've seen some examples of like wow
like that can really yeah get back to
your child yet and how much do I want my
child to be out there I don't think I'm
like in the celebrity world of like that
it would cause a huge difference in her
life but but you never know what could
happen yeah and I'm like and then all
this stuff is out there about her and
about me and about my life and well that
makes me nervous
no you have a it seems like you have a
very rational sense of boundaries and
privacy like a lot of work sizing it
through social media yeah just really a
big stand but okay so talk me through so
you grew up in Detroit yes okay and then
did you come from Detroit straight to LA
yes and I'm gonna have one little
sidebar but yeah because it's a thing in
Detroit yeah I grew up in the suburbs of
Detroit I went to a wedding in the
suburbs of Detroit oh dude let me years
and years ago Bloomfield
hey I believe though I was like a
plus-one so I was like we're going to
Detroit okay and then saw this like a
beautiful light so beautiful area
suburban area yeah most of the people I
meet out here in LA who've been to
Detroit have gone to West Bloomfield
suburbs a suburb of Detroit yeah and I
do want to say like it is a thing with
Detroiters
not gonna say I'm a Detroiter because I
didn't I wasn't born and raised in the
city okay metropolitan Detroit and I
have a lot of friends I'm like you grew
up in Buffalo and you're telling people
you grew up in Detroit
I just want to point that out that I am
a true pilot in Detroit but I went to
school in Detroit and I have such a
great connection second city Detroit oh
yeah yes
so you started doing second city there
how old were you when you started doing
that I was like 20 years old Wow
then I started in second city I was on
the main stage by 21 Wow so what what
drew you to that and 63 no no it's a
what drew you to to improv so I was
mainly a athlete like my goal was to
play volleyball in college really is
what I wanted to do really yeah I had
three older brothers and very sports
driven family I was a jock in high
school I have all brothers and yes I
have three a stepbrother and two brother
amazing yeah you get it our youngest no
I'm kind of middle middle okay so my
middle child but yeah my younger
brothers gays who's kind of my sister so
it's like a little yeah a little bit of
balance but the youngest in that weird
middle and youngest I feel like ya tend
to be the creators artists yes yeah
actors but um but I was a major jock and
then high school I got bit by the
theater bug I just randomly audition
because friend was like do this with me
and I was like and then I did it and I
got like the lead in the play and I was
like well I was like this is fun and
then I kind of I'm sure the same thing
happen to you once you started
performing it's just like you are
obsessed with it yeah ah da da and then
I went to school for it and there was a
second city Detroit at the time which
was we lovingly referred to as like the
little stepchild of the second city of
Chicago and I just took a job I was
going to Wayne State University for
theater for musical theater and I took a
job as a cocktail waitress to pay my way
through school
mm-hmm and I was a junior at the time
and I saw improvisation and I was like
this is freaking magic I don't know
these people do this I fell in love and
really
long story short again it was the most
random break there were no women in
improv at the time they were like yeah
I've women like and that could
potentially be on the stage there and I
was serving drinks and I had started
taking improv in college and I took an
improv class at second city and I was
directed by one of the main stage cast
members and they're like do you want to
audition because we have someone leaving
and so I improvised for like two or
three weeks on the main stage with this
cast Wow
like I'd be surfing they had this joke
where it was like and here's your drug
free and then I'd be like jumping into
the set but um but I did that for like I
auditioned with them for like three
weeks play like three or four sets and
then I was hired on the main stage not
knowing what the hell I was doing so I
basically learned how to improvise on
the second city Detroit stage and it's
nuts for people that don't know how that
system works you audition to get hired
which basically is a paying gig than a
half voice which is amazing it's an
equity gig I quit school I mean I really
I quit college and I was like here's
this journey so I I started with second
city and yeah it's one of the only
equity paying gigs the only way you can
make money as an improviser yeah so I
kind of like struck the lottery yeah out
of the gate and then that kind of began
my second city career which I did for
the next nine years my life yeah it's
okay so then where did you go from
Detroit what Detroit I went to Chicago
City and then I I did the touring
company for about eight months did some
theatrical stuff but then in 2003 I got
hired on the main stage there so I could
well over three years and then it was
off to LA after that and then touring
company means you basically just go
wherever they have shows booked for you
that's correct
yeah and how was that oh my god because
I can't imagine that touring outside of
Chicago doing improv that it's met with
like either this is the greatest thing
ever or what the [ __ ] is happening in
front of us I mean grace don't you want
to get in a van with six other people
make about $50 a show and just learn
about like dry counties
[Music]
dive bars Birmingham just screaming I
have arrived in everything they need but
you're so young and you're like I am
doing yeah when you're making money at
improv it's like yeah you know you're
just an impossible feat impossible yeah
I mean impasse I still have people my
friend Jimmy Maury and I have follow an
improviser we go around to Improv
theaters throughout the country still to
this day and just because we love it
yeah we get to do our two-person show
and we make a little bit of money but
it's more about like work shopping and
just must spending a weekend the girls
weekend together yeah and we love it so
much but um again I I still weirdly get
the feeling of like I can't believe I do
this for a living yeah to talk about
improv and like work with improv
theaters it's like I still feel a little
bit like I made it in that respect but
yeah but in your 20s you're just like if
I can make my rent oh I will eat you
know a white bread and peanut butter if
I get to do that yeah exactly it's all
teens for the rest of my life because
this is the most thrilling thing ever
exactly that's so cool okay so then you
came out to Los Angeles from Chicago or
you got hired on the main stage in
Chicago in Chicago did that for three
years
okay and then moved up to LA it was like
that defining factor that you're like
going out there doing it didn't get SNL
her MADtv there's a little done you know
I need to just kind of explore the
acting yeah portion of it so but yeah I
was I was flown out to SNL and that
didn't happen and no that is I've also
auditioned oh and yeah girl it didn't
saying no I am NOT I I feel like a lot
of things were against me I'm not an
impressionist same I'm not I just kind
of did Internet a little bit when they
were looking for someone that was like I
had a digital presence sure sure and it
was like was that lady shoot when when
was that like to 12 to 11 11 gonna say
like that's kind of when I felt like
yeah yeah yeah yeah but it's the most
insane process like how was it for you
it was ice did you sit in a room for six
hours and then you go out there and mine
was in front of like Tina Fey I couldn't
even see they were all backlit and
shadowy and then Seth Meyers shook our
hands on the way out and that's us I was
like so I guess you were stay in the
room okay
it was very quiet yeah I got some
titters baby I got titters so they
thought were people like suppressing
coughs are you eating a sandwich yeah or
am i funny and I was in a group of like
Andy Sandberg oh wig and they both got
hired yeah
deservedly so I mean there's no there's
never been a part of me that's like yeah
no I was pretty far I was in a very
talented group and God bless and so I
mean that that was what it was
yeah I'm really grateful for it because
so much you know I I'm not a living
regret or you know analyze the past kind
of person anyway but um but what but it
led to so many wonderful things like
coming out to LA and and and all of that
and I'm a huge Kristen Wiig fan and oh
heck yeah I mean like she's mean and
reasonably absolutely wonderfully
talented exactly and I've never met her
but I'd be very nervous because I feel
like she's one of those people that just
like loses humility yeah and like
graciousness yes and you're like so
you're perfect okay this makes my SNL
experience even worse being also amazing
but yeah I've met her a couple of times
and she is all of those things so then
that's another thing you can't like
begrudge mm-hmm talent and a good person
a hundred percent amazing so then you
came out to LA yep and then what were
the first couple years like in LA to do
how long before you came out to LA did
you end up on workaholics oh gosh so
let's see I started working all this in
2010 I came out in 2006 and I had some
failed things that occurred in the
meantime I actually did an improv based
show : thank god you're here that was on
NBC that lasted for seven count'em
episodes whoa before it was tragically
canceled and deservedly so no it was but
it was it was a big Australian show and
and it was an interesting concept
because you had a core cast of
improvisers that I was a part of and we
were given a script okay and then you
had an improviser
I'm sorry celebrities such as yourself
that would come on Chelsea Handler was
on our show away night from Seinfeld all
these people Jason Alexander and they
would not have a script but they would
be given a wardrobe
and they'd walk into a set that was like
a doctor's office and so the first line
they would hear is thank god you're here
doctor we have to perform this surgery
and we'd be like on a script and they
wouldn't oh wow so they'd have to
improvise their way through this script
and see that's a lot for the guest to do
to do and I think that's why we only did
seven episodes I mean it it could
succeed beautifully yes / in you know
improv can go like Bryan Cranston was
amazing amazing scene there were some
scenes that were incredible Chelsea's I
think was hilarious amazing but then
there was some that were like there's no
editing that came yeah yeah it was a lot
of denial and you know much improvising
you've ever done but was beaten yes yeah
and because we're on a script it was
like yo I'm sorry you just told me you
loved me I have to stick to the script
that I do putting as improvisers you're
like I now behold into a script and I
all I want to do is say yes to this
person right now only I'm like why did
you hire yeah you're telling me not to
improvise I have to stick to the script
and yet this other person who's normally
on script is improvising backwards a
little backwards but it was a huge hit
in Australia it was the Australian show
that was a huge hit and they're also
backwards so about my first break so
that was your first break yeah okay and
then what happened from there tons of
commercials I think it was yourself yeah
lots of commercial work which really
paid my way and I honestly miss to a
certain degree really wasn't
I don't think commercials well I like
the one that I got the one that I did
Lowe's what allowed me to move to Los
Angeles so I'm very grateful and
thankful for that but the commercial
auditioning process I'm just not good at
I can't do it that's the one thing I was
gonna say like I missed the actual just
the work and like it's such quick money
right you do kind of get your face out
there and you're a really accessible way
everybody like middle of everybody sees
you
and especially if you get a great
commercial that yeah me and and shows
you off a little bit but or the the
auditioning process I told people this
that are like well what's the difference
from when you were like doing commercial
to no and I'm like honestly I think the
the better jobs I've gotten especially
as of late like the good placement yeah
things like that the people are so much
like nicer and yeah like the directors
are so much more wonderful now you you
in a way that you're not just cattle
exactly and I'm like the biggest egos
I've ever run in with I frankly our
commercial directors not all of them I
have some friends who are commercial
sure I don't want to lump them all
together but like the biggest egos yeah
I cannot believe you're speaking to me
this way yeah like we're doing a cup we
are so like I don't I don't you know
we're you but you realize it's like this
chip on their shoulder like they want to
be doing TV yes that this is like they
think that they're gonna be the next
Scorsese or the next like a Spielberg or
whatever that they are like but they're
doing at iPod do this hungry man TV and
you're just like like so driven to huh
and it really affects them yeah so and
it's kind of an interesting like having
like having some things on my resume
like like the good places yeah like that
and and then kind of maybe doing an
audition or doing a commercial which but
I guess I hadn't done the good place at
the time but but kind of having some
things and then still being like them
right like training almost like I think
I paid my dues and you know that's not
sound like a dick but I'm like I don't
understand where this energy is coming
right let's just keep it light and fun
yeah and I feel like the further I've
gone in my career the I guess cream
rising to the top or whatever the better
people I've worked with the nicer people
which I think my 20 year old self would
have been like oh god if I you know once
I get to the movie land it's gonna be
like everybody's gonna add egos right
people who have money just have egos and
I found I found it to be quite the
opposite which is delightful yeah I
don't know what your experience says no
I also have like I've been I feel like
kind of like lucky in a way to have
worked with like really great people and
maybe like only a very small amount of
times have encountered people that have
been pretty intense yeah
but then I'm also kind of one of those
like really curiously empathetic people
to be like why this must become like
they're hurt like this must be coming
from a broken place in them and so I
can't take this that personally I mean
that's all in hindsight at the time I'm
like [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
I know in some days you're just stabbing
them with daggers but yeah but but I
feel the same way I think it's much more
healthy to come at it like my husband is
terrible road rage and he describes it
it's like I just see the car think
there's a person there I just see the
car and I'm like once I'm like you need
to start thinking about that person yeah
either rushing because they're someone's
hurt or whatever right I read many like
that switch I think I've helped him gain
empathy but I think it like it's the
same with career it's like you know like
something if you yeah if you go like
something's happen to this person ever
or it makes it a lot easier
it makes it easier to tolerate [ __ ]
I think definitely and also just because
I have Catholic guilt from growing up
religion okay on that note we're gonna
take a quick break when we get back on
talk about workaholics a good place and
basically like just being a mom that's
[ __ ] dominating right now when it
comes to shopping for clothes most of us
are amateur says the girl that wears
sweatshirts every day of every week of
every year so why not let professionals
handle it with stitch fix a stylist will
do all of the work for you stitch fix is
an online personal styling service that
delivers your favorite clothing shoes
and accessories directly to you you just
complete your style profile and your
expert personal stylist will send you a
box of hand-picked items from brands you
know and love with exclusive styles you
won't find elsewhere they even have
men's and kids boxes with no
subscription required pick between
autumn
shipments or getting new pieces
on-demand shipping exchanges and returns
are always free plus the $20 styling fee
is automatically applied towards
anything you keep from your box get
started today at stitch fix calm slash
grace and get an extra 25% off when you
keep everything in your box that stitch
fixed Calm / grace stitch fix dot-com /
grace did you binge making a murderer or
the Bundy tapes I sure did both of those
things so many people can't get enough
of true crime stories and if you're one
of them you need to check out crime
junkie it's named one of the best true
crime podcast by rolling stone crime
junkie covers all kinds of true crimes
from the most notorious to the stories
you've never heard before
they'll even make you think twice about
cases you thought you were sure about
their stories are straightforward and
packed with information but told in a
way that makes you feel like you're
talking to your best friend
there are over 85 episodes you can go
binge right now and they have over
50,000 5-star reviews so you know you
won't be disappointed crime junkie
releases new episodes every Monday visit
Apple podcasts Spotify or wherever
you're listening now and search for
crime junkie to get a true crime fix ok
let's talk about the audition pressure
process for workaholics ok well how did
that come about weird like did you know
what it was did you no idea what it was
there's a lot of really weird
circumstances that came with that so I
was the very first actress to audition
for Alice really I was the first person
they brought in that's nuts weird right
yeah so I yeah I was that was the weird
thing and then also I found out later
that onder's uh-huh when I was on the
main stage in Chicago was in the writing
program in Chicago okay I was living in
Evanston that's where his family's from
and he saw me in a show called Red Scare
okay and he and his girlfriend now wife
yeah mother of their two children they
would mimic me in a scene throughout
like for the next he said for the next
like four years I'll just do this thing
inside joke about psycho about a scene
that I did on the show
and so I was the first person audition
and he said that you he was the first
audition he watched and he was like
that's the girl the girl that me and
Emma and he like told the rest of the
boys about me Wow I ended up seeing
another 200 people or so like a crazy
amount of people and then I was brought
in for a callback with the casting and
you know the whole problem yeah I did it
like five times and then finally
auditioned for network and when I met
onder's he's like do you know how crazy
this is when I go around to like these
Improv Theater is I'm like you never
know right who is going to see you yeah
my soon-to-be boss who never even met
the guys to make workaholic right saw me
back in like 2002 that's not and I got a
job that changed my career right because
he liked what I did so it's like we
always tell these improvisers coming up
like you know you're gonna fail and
you're gonna like [ __ ] the bed but like
the least you can do is just try to have
fun every show yeah and respect the
audience that's watching you because you
don't know who's out there not that you
should do every show like my next you
know buddy could be yeah I've heard he's
sneaky like that just shows up places
but um
but yeah it's it's you never know and so
long story short that's how I got that
it was kind of like a real kismet eat
yeah the universe kind of like spared
this up it was a long con yeah script
that I was not know being written and
and also I think just it was the first
time I got to impress embrace playing
one of the most miserable people because
your characters that you play are these
like harsh abrasive women and you are
such a kind sweet lovely person but it's
like true acting thank you
and I I do feel like it's a very weird
thing that I've fallen into a niche wise
but but it also must be therapeutic in a
way to play this person that's
completely seemingly opposite of you to
be like I'm gonna get out all of my ish
through this character 100% yeah I feel
like I was the happiest during like on a
personal level during my time with
because I just like three dudes to just
take out all my venom on yeah totally
safely and get paid for it didn't get
paid for it I could just go with the
rest of my life like left all that at
work in now I can just enjoy myself it's
so true that's so funny like it was the
best honestly I've been in therapy like
as we all have yeah in this business and
it is the most therapeutic to just kind
of get to pour and it seems like a very
fun work environment like there are very
fun humans I've met a couple of them
like on and off camera and like they
just seem like they're a lot like their
characters you know it's heightened
sense of you know character but it also
seems like the environment was just like
I can't believe we get to do this let's
make it the most fun and exactly and and
the improv background that all of them
have or at least respect I think
grinders and Adam and Kyle newett check
have more of the the improv background
but but just coming from that place of
like yes anding and yeah we would always
have fun runs and oh my gosh make it
your own do would you ever oh the
node-red you want to do we'd always do
the script but you know on top of that
get to play which for me is a dream you
know 20 year old self is like oh my and
how long did you do that show for six
years we did seven seasons in six years
yeah so we did one which is one year
where we doubled up and that was crazy
those poor boys anymore exhausted but
but yeah yeah I can't believe it's like
over it feels like yesterday but then it
also feels like so long ago like I miss
everybody so much you become such a
wonderful dysfunctional family that you
just can't believe you don't get to see
every day anymore but we all still
really keep in touch right my wedding
you know they you know launders came to
my baby shower like Ponder's and I have
particularly maintained a great
relationship that's really great that's
very those guys are the best and then
look at them you know look at you only
and Jillian's one of my dearest friends
and they're all just doing so great and
we're all happy and it's just it's nice
to see and that's a very rare thing that
show gets that lifeline like that's so
nuts and you're in it being like I'm
gonna do the best I can but this is so
many other factors that like here's
fingers crossed so we get to keep doing
that hundred percent that first season I
was like if I don't get to keep doing
this like but then luckily it caught
fire but especially with the Comedy
Central show too I feel like a lot of
them it like the reno 9-1-1
which workaholics did yeah i know some
events like two three seasons I eat two
threes like great shows yeah yeah I'm
gone so it was just great that we caught
fire like that do you have people that
come up to you in the street as Alice
like it's this and is it
what's the is it majority like young
boys yes and now it's good because like
it's catching fire with new like younger
generation because it's yeah my nephew's
couldn't watch it at the time because
they were like seven yeah you know and
now they're like in their teens and it I
think you're the coolest aunt oh you
can't believe you were doing this and
I'm like yeah I'm glad because I would
have ruined you would you would not be
able to look at me they say I'm kind of
uncomfortable now that you have seen
those eggs yeah so it's weird cuz even
younger I think the weirdest thing is
just when like and this is kind of weird
to point out but like I did at the time
have like 13 14 year old fans right
would be kind of weird on Twitter like
oh and another reason probably why I've
shied away from social media because you
know the show itself kind of lends
itself to such a body I'm being very
political diplomatic about yeah
it's a real dirty show and so these
young kids would just be like kind of
saying vulgar things if I like they've
permission to like Google you ogle you
say things that like if you like why am
i preaching to the choir I'm sure you
know something you I don't you with that
the I have you've been kind of lumped
into a crowd that their fan base is
celebrating and supporting like men
being a certain way yeah
even though also gets complicated in the
hashtag me too world yeah like we kind
of just missed that yeah so I can't
imagine oh wow yeah how my character
would be viewed or how the guy at some
of the humor of the show would be you
know I've thought about that a lot of
like oh my god we were of a time yeah I
don't think that show laughter and
everything yeah yeah I mean God bless
you Millennials like I love Amy I don't
know if you've seen any Schumer's
stand-up special I haven't seen it yeah
yeah well she she just has this great
bit not ruining anything for you or
she's like weren't didn't the
Millennials do something for our
generation that we so appreciate where
they came up and we're like um can you
believe this is happening and then my
generation is like yeah that is kind of
weird and the Millennials are like yeah
you do you want to change this and we're
like yeah I do kind of want to change
that like that's great bit where you're
like you guys just point like put into a
light some things that yeah I think
we've just been in comedy especially
better or worse yeah don't wonderful and
absolutely necessary and then you know
there's some points where you're like
what now what can anyone say about
anything and that's what's scary too I
talk about that a lot of like the
political correctness like yeah I would
not want to be an improviser coming up
right now yes you have to like literally
dodge landmines when you're learning how
to improvise yeah and if you do
something like I did so many
inappropriate things oh yeah I made a
joke this is so awful but on stage at
the Second City I mean a joke about the
tsunami happening and it had just
happened and it was New Year's Eve and
my cast had been celebrating we had some
champagne backstage I went out and I was
like barf like this really distasteful
joke could have ended with the letters
were written oh wow it's really bad and
I felt terrible it was just a slip it
wasn't my heart no it's not your
intention it's not it is a bad mistake
yeah and that's career-ending now like
if it's done oh that's my improv it's
been in a podcaster and you know it
probably scary because you can't edit it
out you know literally in the moment so
you have to be that much more cognizant
of every single thing that you are
saying and in this hyper PC world it's
not good luck like I'm glad I
he's out of that scene yes okay so let's
talk about the good place okay
how did this happen I mean this is a
show that's like massive like
workaholics it's huge yeah I'm not I'm
slightly familiar I haven't done a full
deep dive on everything no worries but
it's obviously like people love it its
massive it's one of those like hits that
rarely happens
yeah culty show yeah so I worked on
Parks and Recreation and that's where I
met Mike Schur and Amy Poehler and if
you can believe it this is the first
time that there's something like this
big has happened in my career but it was
an offer like he Wow they had I guess
thought of me for Mindy square out of
the gate which was so flattering
yeah I'm still kind of like really like
I played this time I know well okay
think about it I'm like why was that so
surprising to me miserable cocaine
addict from like the 80s like that's the
deal with warm beer and yeah this medium
place but um but yeah so it was an offer
and this is such an insecure actor thing
but my first response
honestly grace was like okay who dropped
out she's like no you know what they
thought of you and just own it and enjoy
it like all right why can't I just like
enjoy yeah why don't we we had Tony Hale
on a couple weeks ago he said the same
thing it's like imposter syndrome of
being like I don't belong here am I
gonna be found out but they like they
they offered to the wrong person it's
always like they know who I am right
there not confusing me with a Meredith
like it's so true but yeah so I was
offered it and I was not deep I did not
do a deep dive on the show until I was
casted out of Lee and I was like oh my
god this show looks so weird and so
broad and it's like it it was not what I
thought on first viewing yeah and the
more I've watched the show and I think
the more America's watched the show is
this very philosophical show very smart
yeah so
in but also with this very relatable
comedy and it's like bright colors in
this very surreal world so I just feel
like it it um it's just
naturally I'm blanking on the word I'm
trying to fight but it like entry it's
intriguing to everybody and a big
demographic a cast a wide net yeah also
I heard you on like a good place podcast
talking about how like they didn't tell
you and like you had to be informed when
you got a set like here's kind of a
really something to this right still so
sets top secret I filmed two weeks ago
and I was just given like you're seeing
yes
and like and like rough outline of like
what's to be so I don't know if I'm
gonna be I don't know what's coming up I
don't really give you enough to act love
to act and like rough outlines but they
you know I think the show because of the
reveals that they've done have been so
epic right that they're just uber
protective when like so I don't know if
I'm coming back this season I hope so
but I hope that wasn't it for Mindy but
that's also so insane I don't think
people understand with actors and
actresses that you you get your you know
storyline yeah and you get the episodes
that you're in and then you just kind of
have to sit and wait and hope that the
writers decide that you should be part
of exactly and that you've done a good
job and you kind of like hope that the
audience's loved me enough and you wanna
see me back but and all indicators point
in that way but it's also like oh god
what if that was it it is that yeah when
I'm like am I saying goodbye to Mindy is
this the last time on the set so it's
weird but but super fun and I'm grateful
but yeah yeah it's like yeah it's a
weird thing
what's the fan base like for the good
place versus definitely some ladies are
involved which is real fun love you lady
but it's been an interesting cuz I've
had just as many people come up to me
about a good place than I did as
workaholics and I think it's like
network cable you know I sure more
people are seeing it but it is kind of
this wild thing of like I've only done
four episodes of this show and people
like the show like there's just so much
I love about it's impactful and the
characters been impactful but but yeah
it's been lovely and I feel like oh god
I'm I'm not gonna be in a bar and have
like you know god bless you all but
drunk frat boy come in my life that is
flat-out happened where I'm eating meal
with friend boys sits in lap and I'm
like I'm not your mommy and dinner
yeah I'm not Santa or your mother so
please leave and only time I got really
like pissy with a man but I was like
that's incitements a 100% warrant thank
you what do you watch in your own time
if anything what do you do for fun what
do i well the last seven months have
been lady baby baby baby so it's been a
lot of no sleep and just trying to like
keep up on content yes as you know I'm
sure that you know you've fall into the
same thing of just needing to keep up on
content for what I do you know
so obviously I'm a game of Thrones fan
definitely watch that that's been a big
escape during baby times like that but I
just finished shrill with oh I don't
even know is there Ian oh my god it is
standing she she is you know 80 Brian
yeah yeah now so she just kind of like
takes on like a millennial perspective
on dating oh yes we weren't talking
about this in a recent episode yeah and
she is just like so good
she's so comedic aliy wonderful on SNL
and then to get to watch her do this I
was like I have a whole new I'm out
brand your hand i watch a lot of
stand-up so Amy Schumer special like I'm
big fans do you do stand-up No
I am terrified of that same eared Li I
would never it's the one thing I will
I've done improv that stand-up ISM so
scary
he's been loneliest like miss me yeah
and some get naked yeah Amy Schumer
flashed her I don't want to ruin that
like she was pregnant and like you know
I some actually get naked but yeah I
need someone up there with me yeah like
I'll go for it but I want someone to
bail make sure there's possible but it's
a lot of stand-up um trying to think I
watch a lot of documentaries okay tell
me I need recommendations so just watch
the heart of gold' the new on HBO about
the gymnastics oh I haven't seen that
one yet this is the thing and tell me if
you do the same thing because you're in
a you're in a very light-hearted world
like comedy and everything so i weirdly
gravitate towards darker yeah i watch
all of the every like serial killer all
the murder everything yeah not to get
too deep yeah but i I went through
before I had my daughter I went through
miscarriage and it was it was
therapeutic for me cuz the only thing I
could watch her shows that had no
children in it yeah no laughter no jokes
because I didn't want to see other
people be feeling yeah I noticed but it
was like this two weeks of Forensic
Files yeah and you know I looking back
on it with a sense of humor I was like
oh my god hoarders my 600-pound like
these terrible things were I'm like why
it was like doubling down but it's like
it was all I could do
yeah I couldn't but it was myself a
little sense I mean I my guilty
pleasures all reality television yeah
yeah is garbage for your brain a brain
just wants to have an easily digestible
meal do you know my friend Amy Phillips
who does all the Real Housewives
impersonations yes yeah so she so that's
her whole world yeah is like is like
that you think that your tiger she's
amazing she she has her own show Sirius
Radio about this but but but but yes so
so I'm really into the doctor like
darker documentaries I watched all of
actually be on a lighter note Serena
Williams
documentary on ETO on a plane what do
you think I was it was a little I liked
it because I think she drools and yeah
really cool it just ended yes that's
what I was like I only have I watched it
on the plane and like a full flight
watch check all the episodes and then I
was like do they only have this many
episodes on this play or is this how it
ends
oh it's how it ends okay so it was
there's a brown thing that worked at him
like you're Serena Williams you deserve
like an epic ten episodes and so
under-produced
is like how are you under produced it
was a very interesting series yeah I had
the breast pumping and I was I was going
through all of this at the time so yeah
so pumping and then her running out and
do we like like this I haven't washed my
hair in three days like this time not is
like the look next week like this girl
is I know and just crushing on a tennis
court like and it's so nuts to me
because I don't know what it's like to
be an elite athlete in any way but the
idea that like she's going out and
practicing to try and get back on her
game and people just find her court and
just watch her and he's like oh you're
just under a microscope all the time and
it's so nuts also I love that being this
was like she beat me but I like to think
it was two against one
oh my god you guys are adorable and how
does that work think about that jeepers
like they must have such an amazing
relationship or the worst
it's either dysfunctional or brilliant
for them yeah yeah no I like that series
I had the same exact kind of no not
notes I'm not a network executive but I
was just like oh I wanted more from this
I don't know what I wanted but a little
bit more her husband is like the
sweetest human much and that
relationship was fascinating because
they are very I guess they're not
compass it in the sense of like
businesspeople like she seems very
business minded to me and obviously he
is amazingly business minded so that
made sense yeah like otherwise just like
not who I would anticipate her falling
in love with but like I think I get that
does good work because it seems so kind
of come
lately out of left field and someone
that's that driven and has succeeded
that much and has to have such an armor
of like strength and like I'm a role
model yeah I'm an icon and I've
shattered stereotypes yeah you want
someone who's just gonna take care of
that person like I want her to have
someone who just like you can be as
vulnerable as you want you can be as
like you know flawed as you want I'm
just gonna I'm gonna treat you like it
you know like a princess like yeah
that's what I took away to of like I
kind of like your maternal instincts are
kicking in you're like I want for Sarina
to have someone okay we can make one
last break and when we get back we have
Twitter questions from your favorite
forum this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by skin you heard me
right there are those among us with an
insatiable thirst for adventure the ones
who embrace the unknown with wide-eyed
wonder although your dreams might take
you worlds away
you shouldn't neglect what's right in
front of you skin's new line of intimate
devices is designed to take your
pleasure to new undiscovered places like
the skin vibes a quiet yet powerful
massager made to meet your unique needs
and body skin vibes has a curved sensual
shape it can take you from zero to Oh
with twenty different speeds and
pulsations because when it comes to
pleasure there is no one-size-fits-all I
sincerely hope my parents aren't
listening to this episode don't settle
for monotony explore intimacy with skin
vibes available for purchase at Rite Aid
skin feel everything this episode of not
too deep is brought to you by better
help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help online
counseling can help they offer licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in issues such as depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family
conflicts LGBT matters grief self-esteem
and more they connect you with the
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment and get help
at your own time at your own pace having
anything you share is confidential it's
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapist and if for some
reason you're not happy with your
counselor you can request a new one at
any time for no additional charge and
best of all it's affordable and not too
deep with grace helbig listeners get a
10% discount off your first month with
the discount code grace so get started
today go to better help calm slash grace
simply fill out a questionnaire to help
them assess your needs and get matched
with the counselor that you'll love
that's better help calm slash grace okay
Marybeth before we get into these
Twitter questions I'm gonna ask you the
two questions asked every single guest
raised on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most wanna
throw cold spaghetti act cold spaghetti
at mm-hmm I would say I'm Rand oh wow I
start by saying I respect you as being
one of the only female philosophers in
history that truly impacted generations
people and as a feminist sister I think
that's amazing yeah but what she's put
out that fuels now a very twisted party
she's the philosopher that is kind of
the one of the faces of the Republican
Party to which I very much stand against
I have to say she feeds the minds mine
as well
I read her at 21 yeah most people read
most college-age kids read her because
it's the first philosopher that kind of
explores being being independent and you
know it's you against the world and it's
very anti altruism it's very anti
charity yeah and tight
it's really about like just being
selfish and I think and it paints it in
a very like it will help the world but
ultimately I think it's one of the most
dangerous philosophies to brewing into
young especially young privileged white
male mind yeah and I think she has
really unfortunately been a huge
catalyst in that Wow
privileged world so that make sense I
kind of would throw spaghetti I wouldn't
hurt her but no said throw spaghetti
yeah cold spaghetti I would throw cold
spaghetti it's in and they would send
her into a like a whirlwind of what does
this mean how dare you in a very Russian
the other question ask every guest is to
tell us your worst pants [ __ ] story
or like a close call but you can only
use three words or three small phrases
so mine is college jogging front lawn
audition Santa Monica 405 no no luck
leaves after okay thank God thank God
but I was very ill and I just know the
405 it was bumper-to-bumper there's no
getting off I feel like we've had a few
people that have had their [ __ ]
stories surrounded by either the 10 or
the 405 in Los Angeles traffic I am just
tons of tragedy on roads oh I don't know
why they don't make cars with like just
you can open up the see yeah just like
maybe that's what an RV is I told you
that's like it for LA that would sell
like hot ok I mean the new Tesla's I
feel like gonna be insane ok let's go
into this Twitter questions
some wants to know how does it feel
being a boss ass [ __ ] that gets [ __ ]
done it only happens on TV but I I do
love that I get to have that experience
in a fictional way I wish it was it bled
more into my real life but it feels good
is there another type of character that
is outside of who you like naturally are
that you would want to play oh yeah I
mean this isn't I do think I'm a
relatively nice kind good love to play
that yeah Janu days are over
I think my rom come on jinwu days are
never happened because I'm definitely
character actors but I would love to be
like the love interest that's kind of
boring but sweet that is so fun I think
the departure I love Li ng my my
miserable characters I think that that's
you playing a character actress okay
if she could pick one person to live
alone in the medium place with who would
it be
like on the show or am i casting a net
like in the world like on the show on
the show I mean either one so I've
worked the most with Kristen and she's
delightful and I think I think they have
enough similarities the characters that
they could find some common ground if
they had to they were stuck on the
medium place like especially with her
past yeah but I haven't worked a lot
with Ted Danson or Maya Maya Rudolph so
they show them I would love to be stuck
in the medium place with and maybe I'll
get that chance like on this season but
those two I'm such like cheers I like
grew up on yeah Ted Danson is just like
the TV show my TV show like dad yeah cuz
Bill Cosby kind of ruined that and so
now I've moved on to Ted someone to know
from one Mary Beth to another as a child
were you upset you couldn't find magnets
with your name on oh god bless this Mary
Beth yes it was really a bummer and you
had to settle for the ma ry which which
by the way my legal name is ma ry page
but my Screen Actors game name is ma RI
ba ta bad because in the fifth grade
grace it's a long story I was in a
Lutheran School and we were learning
about the Virgin Mary uh-huh and I
didn't want to be called Mary
because I just felt like it was too much
to live up to so I was like Maria Marin
I'm like I gotta do something here these
names so I literally started just
spelling my name with an eye and my mom
was like the teacher said you're
spelling your name with an eye and I'm
like I do not want to be like the Virgin
which what other kid would make any
other kid would be like I want to be
like oh my god amazing name like I'm the
I'm the mother of Jesus and I was like
oh god I can't do much I know this life
is going and I'm gonna ruin that I
cannot endure an immaculate conception
no thank you pressure but yeah but I was
so sad about but yes I was so sad about
the magnets and I'd had to settle for
marry which goes against everything my
you know itself wanted to change yeah
how many times you get called Meredith
oh constant like in casting sessions I'm
like I know I'm not like huge celebrity
but like Kenyan look at you're just like
I just want to go to Meredith yeah I get
it it's a pretty name but yeah it's
frustrating it's annoying that is
annoying someone to know what is harder
as a comedic actor TV or improv oh I
would say I would probably combine like
improvising on TV like I do feel like
sometimes when they're like alright
funrun Mary Beth dazzle us and fun
Kristen Bell's right over there and you
know Jason Mantzoukas let's hear the fun
and I'm like oh god now I'm on the spot
so that's and there's no audience so
you're just like advising another God so
that's a little must be quiet so people
can't laugh so they we're used to yeah
they're like what's that good I have no
idea that's the hardest in general I
would say I think improv is ultimately
the hardest firm that I've tried to
tackle or tried to be successful at and
you guys do an improv show that is it a
charity driven show the
for the Detroit creativity yes so we've
done it once before it's called them the
forking shirt show yeah
per the good place language and it's
great like this time we're gonna have
Kristen Bell and Dax Shepard I was gonna
be there and then Jason Mantzoukas Sean
who plays Sean Maher Kevin Jackson my
friend he hosts it for his charity and
is it going to be eventually like a
running show or just kind of whatever
amazing was bad thing if we could like
tour that I'll be back in the van baby
yeah down no but I think I mean that
would be incredible but I think it's
probably gonna be more one-off just
because of schedules I mean I don't know
that Kristen Bell wants to tour a show
right yeah little busy with like frozen
wood okay last question someone to know
what's the worst and best advice that
you've ever gotten and that you've ever
given the worst and best advice I've
ever gotten okay so I don't know if this
was advice like one of the first casting
meet-and-greets I've ever done which I'm
sure you've done where you just it's no
audition you just kind of go and it's a
go seer and yeah yeah and I was just out
of Michigan just out of Chicago to LA
but I'm very green yeah and you can hear
my accent now like daddy like it goes up
into the nose Michigan knows a little
bit and it was really prominent when I
first came to LA and I sat down with
this casting director and she we had
this great meeting and she's like well I
just think you're delightful and you
know I'll keep you in mind for things
she's like but I got to ask is this
whole Midwest thing you're doing is this
real or is this something that's kind of
like putting on for the meeting because
apparently my my accent was off the
charts and so I was like no this is
really how I talk and she's like keep it
love it it's great so it was just such a
weird like I'm like that was like the
meanest you're the weirdest thing to be
called out on yeah that I'm that clever
like this Midwest character like I know
it's gonna bust
I know it's gonna make waves in LA this
nasal ass accent and this sweetest
pumpkin pie did behavior I'm gonna come
in naive talking through my nose get a
lady special so that was that and then
the the worst advice I've ever given
that's the best I've ever gotten the
worst I've ever given god I give great
advice grace what's the advice that you
would give to people that are either
wanting to pursue improv and get into
entertainment or like want to move like
you did like what's the thing that
really you think is like the most
motivating or like sound piece that you
wish someone told you you know it's
gonna sound super cliche but sure I feel
like I've had those moments I try not
like I said try not to look back in my
past and go regret or like I should have
done this different I think that's all a
big waste of time but there was a period
of my life where I was like oh should I
have moved out to LA when I was 20 like
I didn't move out till I was like 29
like would I have made better strides
and I came out earlier and I've come to
the place where I'm I feel so grateful
for the things I did get to accomplish
that I feel like if you do and I stayed
at second city because I loved it it's
like I really want to do the main stage
I love improv I followed my heart I
followed my passion and I and now
looking back I'm like I never would have
gotten workaholics if I didn't do that
he had never would have gotten this if I
didn't do that I'm a you know who knows
what would have happened but I feel like
if if you love where you're at even if
it's like Cleveland Ohio Improv Theater
but you're loving what you're doing I
think if you go at it a hundred percent
everything will it'll your path the way
suppose the way it's supposed to some
whoever's gonna find you will find you
yeah the career opportunities will find
you but if you're doing it 100% with
your heart and I feel like I would I
know this is me not interviewing you but
I feel like making your way in the way
that you made your way was out of your
passion out of your heart and changing
your gut like this is something I like
to do I don't think anyone else really
knows or likes this yet but I really
like it so I'm going to keep pursuing
this and then
percent I think also the real thing that
stuck out to me that you said earlier is
just like you never know who's gonna see
you so you just show up your best
however that means to you every time and
in person you know things like that you
know you never know when it's gonna pay
off ten years later and you're in Los
Angeles and now you have a you're on a
show totally and like not worrying about
the rent yeah so much like like trying
to let go of the money like that wanting
the money so bad and yeah we all want
the money sure if you let go of that I
feel like that's why got homes yeah as
opposed to making choices right I think
that's super valid and really great Mary
but thank you so much for being here
before you go you know every guess it's
on the podcast gets a personalized
fortune cookie from my sister so you can
take it and eat it can I do it right now
yeah a divorce yeah you can read what's
inside there's nothing inside just like
how can I read it to every bit of course
you come so uh we actually DMD your
fortune like a year ago but since you're
never on Instagram I guess you never got
it and the request expired but that's
fine
it's whatever we're not mad mad just a
little mad so when you get a chance go
back and check your DMS I definitely
have never checked my dear oh my god I
don't don't should I not do it all but
now I feel so much pressure like I don't
know because of hearing the fan base
that you've had via workaholics do not
check okay maybe but where can people
find you and what you're up to
yeah the perfect timing on this go ahead
oh where can people find you and what
you're up to
I didn't I thought you didn't finish the
mother crunching in um so uh we have
this great charity show coming up I get
to plug that on this I think will go up
after the charity oh well okay yeah so
I'm a part of a group called mama's boy
we perform at the Second City Hollywood
it's like every other month we do a show
on Tuesdays so maybe check out the
website their second City Hollywood I'm
on twit
very rarely but it's at Marybeth Monroe
um I'm on Facebook but unfortunately I
have so many friends I won't be able to
friend it and then you know I don't know
when this episode of the good place I
just shot it a couple weeks ago that'll
be coming out on uh I just shot a pilot
called for CBS called Bob Hart's Abba
Shola
that's a new Chuck Lorre show sweet that
um I don't it might be picked up by the
time this airs we'll see or you'll never
hear of it again amazing I hope it goes
and that hopefully you'll come out in
the fall maybe if we go so you also have
a movie called bootstrapped right oh so
um it's actually it's a television show
that made it to Sundance this year yeah
and we are shopping it around we were
trying to sell it so so fun thank you so
much for being here I really appreciate
it thank you for having me of course
we'll see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye 2deep
2deep 2deep 2deep whatever struggles you
were facing from depression and anxiety
to trauma and grief better help can
connect you with a professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment it's convenient you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
or chat and text with your therapist and
anything you share is completely
confidential and it's affordable not too
deep with grace Helbig listeners even
get 10% off your first month with the
discount code grace so get started by
going to better help calm slash grace
and fill out a questionnaire to get
matched with the counselor you'll love
today not too deep is a production of
grace helbig incorporated producer and
edited by melissa demons writing by
diane kang a production assistants by
Katrina Henning post-production sound by
Chris Henry and an extra special thanks
to Flula for the theme music
[Music]